bello e tutti ragazzi e prendere di
questo video sono va vj oggi siamo in
pigiama sonno in pigiama
perché non c'è scritto da nessuna parte
che non posso fare un vino in pigiama
niente ragazzi allora mi è successo che
aprite ho giocato un paio di giochi che
dopo averli giocati ho detto ma chi
cazzo sto facendo della mia vita ho
voluto metterle insieme entrambi in
questo video quindi ragazzi a cosa più
strana che potreste mai vedere nella
vita dopo il mio pigiama l'ex che cerca
adesso ditemi se questo non è il menù
più figo che voi abbiate mai visto che
tutta la vostra vita assolutamente per
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono fa vj questo è un videogioco pieno
di sonoro pieno gli effetti speciali e
di grafica
se noi andiamo su chloé che mi sono
giusto free the two one grazie ho messo
la maglietta bianca un gioco tutto
bianco vi sembra di essere in paradiso
quale di questi e rovato il biscotto no
direi ecco questo io sono un biscotto e
cioè anche ragione tu non sono stato io
perché non ho le braccia e perciò anche
raggio il cazzo questo e bob io non sono
un uomo dai bob sei stato tu di la vita
uno dei tre deve averlo preso per forza
se non è possibile a meno che non è
stato lui cazzo nascosto next mission se
l'ho fatto è stato difficile è veramente
clic clic in steam lui e steve passato
cos'è
quasi che mangi che cosa deve mangiare
il cus a del mouse si faccia in cos'è
sta roba per chi è rega non mi vomita to
tecnici compri la sua nudità come batte
col culo c'è scritto culo sul culo la
cina mi veloce devo trascinandolo
trascina stato perfetto mix rocket
preparare questo razzo con la pizza con
la pizza riparliamo il razzo con la
pizza giusto posto gli ok possiamo
decollare cosa devo fare perché c'è una
pizza che il caso ne faccio della pizza
o è sparita la pizza che è successo ma
si mette dentro la pizza prefetto adami
la pianta perfetto di cacciavite grano e
cacciavite no quello non serve un
ingranaggio questa sottospecie di di
shuttle a cazzo a posto find me trekking
parte che sembra bay max su cose perché
anche due motori chiedi chi è diverso
ragazzino ragazzi perché in questo mondo
siamo tutti uguali tutti o quasi chi è
diverso tra questi che cazzo ne so io mi
sembra la mia prof quando doveva
interrogare che andava scelta così a
cazzo se come si sta nascondendo eccolo
a chi che ha visto che sorrideva questo
è bello 6 quel sorriso che paga la
telecamera zio fenomeno è il port
security sicurezza l'aeroporto bene
allora devo assicurarmi che tu non sia
un terrorista perdonami ecco perfetto io
ce l'avevo di ferro quindi suonava
cancelliamo questa cosa dal video grazie
cioè tu sei pulito a voi di fare una
scansione degli organi ma quello dopo
sei punito anche tra chi cazzo è al
secondo me quello che aveva no chi è che
devo controllare scusate il mio punto
lui che cosa devo fare anche noi prima
cosa è successo e mi bari home qualcuno
a casa adesso né al campanello il suono
del campanello è la cosa più bella che
io abbia mai sentito nella mia vita non
sono un cazzo è una roba c'è l'audio di
questo gioco è memorabile
io ancora non ho capito il senso di quel
enjoy mai surround sound addome ma
perché devo metterli le orecchie legava
cos'è finito l'omessa funziona così in
borsa metà di loro no
va bene facciamo che eccolo qua perfetto
sei un figo ok
devo spegnerle una per una se cose
perfetto premi tease spegni ti perfetto
riscontro anzi avevo desiderato di avere
una chela di granchio sul braccio esatto
ciò istanti evo devo vestire gioco oddio
perché ciò è diventata una tartaruga
ragazze già sta diventando delle persone
brutte
joe è sparito piena ieri menta devo devo
firmare sa cosa mister funky noi non
sono mister funky questo questo perché
se un insetto accetto di mangiare il
cibo schifoso farcela ecco adesso non va
più bene perché dove harry potter che
problemi hai al cervello e nel bagno
delle donne sicuramente cos'è dov'è il
mio ragazzo magico che cazzo ne so dove
harry si qui dentro per caso 36 torniamo
indietro in questo sei tu eri no tu non
sei archi 6 a ritroso cercare a
riportarne i cessi cioè vi rendete conto
il problema
ecco trovato mi sono perso è trovato sei
tranquillo ai doni venaus xodo trovare
qualche cosa right click cosa clicca qui
per vincere già veramente di capi per
non vincere giochi così impostazione
clicca qui per non vincere il gioco non
voglio vincere il gioco ho perso se ho
vinto la pera su perico e questo era il
primo ragazzi secondo è leggermente più
strano ancora ma va bene tutto vostro
appello a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti
possiamo video sono fa vj oggi siamo su
non mi ricordo come si chiama ma il
gioco di una mosca che vola l'ho
scaricato perché è strano ma strano
forte la modalità storia di sta cosa va
bene play press and to skip story
[ __ ] la storia nome ne frega
niente devo io non è che io io schiaccio
la mosca non è che la in persona
perfetta
[ __ ] loriga [ __ ] vieni qua la gli
skill maicon e kakà sono saltato sul
muro tipo famiglia di testa è morta o vi
non ho capito un cazzo pasteris cosa
devo fare o prenderla testate in poche
parole mai con una brutta [ __ ] vini
potenti non mi devi sfasciare icahn o il
televisore va bene va bene succede
[Musica]
parimenti con l'arco con un tasso faccio
ripartire la musica bellissima ovunque
devo non posso annunciare gli oggetti
telecomando telecomando
il tavolo c'è il tavolo per una mossa
che non era esattamente la cosa giusta
da cipro dove è quella [ __ ]
vieni qua stronzo ma come faccio lancia
mille cose ho capito ragazzo l'ho già
fatta lo fanno capito come si lanciano
gli oggetti poi finita di cactus i caps
michael giuro che non volevo
ma guarda che mira di merda ciò regata
limitata
sì sì vieni qua no domanda dai ke kazzo
meglio prima come cazzo fate ucciderla
subito no è mica non la prendono mai
rega impossibile da i trojan no no no 2
ma va giuro che mi sono rotto i [ __ ]
veramente che togliti straw bisogno di
te quando serve dove sei ha trovato un
cesso ragazzi col c'è successo è la
risposta a tutto ma [ __ ] dai
parchi già mi suicido comodino di merda
l'ho presa
[Musica]
[ __ ] tutto ci posso credere
marino giuro che ora ragazzi stato in
quanto strano lo so lo so ho detto
questo vado a fare colazione
anche se non credo da merita abbia più
un senso ha previsto ste cose che i
ragazzi servizio è piaciuto non si è
cacciato momento mi piace ogni mi piace
che mettete è un gesto di solidarietà
nei confronti dei pigiami abbandonati
senza dovresti di scriverti nocivi
diavolo fosse unito e da ragazzi